[Musique]
bonjour vous 'branche Sur un répondeur
téléphone Je suis absent pour la
journée veuillez laisser votre nom votre
numéro de téléphone ou baiser
message DS mon retour je vous
rappellerai attention Au top sonore
parle tout c'est Moi Oh Je t'appelle
On dirait juste que j'embrasse
je te comprendrai
parler puis que Je suis seule et puis
que tu manques et que sans toi bah
c'est
drle j'ai l'impression de Ne pasexister
vraiment
Je suis devenu ta choisi quoi alors tu
m'oublie pas trop puis tu me rappelles
vite vite il a tout
[Musique]
[Des rires]
Heure bonjour vous 'branché sur un
Répondeur téléphonique Je suis absent
pour la journée veuillez laisser votre
Nommez votre numéro de téléphone ou Au
embrasse un message DS mon retour Je vous
rappellerai attention Au top
Son
parle coucou ton Encore
Moi monsieur donne pas trop de ses
nouvelles sur ressembler à c'est pas que je m'
seulement IL est bient TT 8h et Je n Ai
J'ai préparé un petit Diner comme
le plein de petites
surprises des croquettes enf de choses
croquer
quoi peut mme Moi on Ne sait
jamais alors maintenant sagira de
[Musique]
venir
bonjour vous êtes un répondeur
téléphone Je suis absent pour la
journée veillez laissez votre nom votre
numéro de téléphone ou baiser
message DS mon retour je vous
rappellerai attention Au top sonore
parle IL est 9h
et30 ton téléphone appelle le tien
tu t'en fous de quoi quand je pensais ça
j'aurais pu tomber vraiment amoureuse
d'un MEC dans ton genre Je préfère en
rire
Tu as alors, tu vois tes histoires
minables avec ces bonnes femmes tes
rendez-vous cartouche Tous ces trucs tu te
Les gardes et puis Moi tu mets une cie
dessus je t'assure c'est mieux c'est
mieux pour nous deux
[Musique]
salut à tous, c'est vous tous
répond enfin c'est Moi j'ai retardé par
rendez-vous d'affaires
tu es pas
stupide
répond juste quelqu'un mot j'entends le son
de ta
voix tout
tous là
bonjour vous ttes branché Sur un
répondre
phone Je Ne suis pas inutile de
laissez votre nom votre numéro
téléphone ou un
message ne serait rien du
tout c'est Plus la peine c'est trop tard
beaucoup trop tard absence
[Musique]
prolongée
que